from coffee breaks to disappearing
extras and rubber swords there have been
some unexpected sights in Westeros over
the years here's a few of the biggest
on-screen mistakes you can catch and
chuckle at throughout Game of Thrones
during the fourth episode of Game of
Thrones eighth and final season the
majority of the show's characters found
themselves celebrating their victory
against the army of the dead at
Winterfell in a raucous party scene
filled with drinking games dirty jokes
and even a marriage proposal as Jon Snow
is venerated by his friends for his
valiant efforts during the Battle of
Winterfell and Daenerys watches a coffee
cup is clearly visible on the table in
front of her sticking out like a sore
thumb among mugs of ale goblets of wine
and other medieval style props typical
of thrones' time and style naturally
fans didn't let this pass quietly and
they stormed the internet to make a
million Starbucks jokes and even the
cats got in on the joke HBO for their
part released a jokey statement about
the mistake but went on to digitally
remove the cup from the episode
throughout the series run Game of
Thrones viewers have watched Daenerys
Targaryen pick up titles amass armies
free the downtrodden and experienced
enormous overall character growth as she
evolves from a meek naive child bride to
one of the most powerful players in the
Seven Kingdoms as she fights her way to
the iron throne
Daenerys learns new traditions from the
different tribes and people she
encounters along the way and one of them
has to do with her hair and it's very
specific styling thanks to Daenerys his
first love called Drogo one of Daenerys
signature traditions is to keep her hair
long and continue to add complicated
braids to her updos braids indicate
battle victories for the Dothraki and
long hair means you haven't yet been
defeated by your enemies with that many
braid wigs laying around it's probably
hard to keep track and sharp-eyed
viewers caught a rare wig error during
the first episode of thrones' 8th season
as Daenerys rides in to Winterfell
alongside Jon Snow her wig visibly
changes displaying a totally different
braid style between two quick shots
Daenerys is hair is a pretty important
symbol but sometimes even the crew
probably has trouble remembering which
rig goes on when that many wigs would
make anyone go a little crazy
throughout eight seasons fans have
become quite familiar with Game of
Thrones sets and various locations
since the beginning the show has made
use of incredible natural beauty across
the world to bring the seven kingdoms to
life from quiet shores in Spain to the
rolling green hills of Northern Ireland
snowy spots in Iceland and ancient
Croatian cities Thrones has utilized
some of the most gorgeous places on
earth to serve as stand-ins for these
fantastical locations these incredible
filming locations give the show a sense
of enormous scale and richness that
digital effects alone would never create
as the capital of the Seven Kingdoms
King's Landing is one of the grandest
locations on the show positioned as a
large city that sits directly on the sea
even though it gets a digital makeover
every time it shows up that city is
actually a real place Thrones set their
King's Landing scenes in the real city
of Dubrovnik Croatia known as the jewel
of the Adriatic which now draws hordes
of visitors every year thanks to its
prominent screen time on the show for
the vast majority of that screen time
the gates of King's Landing looked out
on a green pastoral space and then in
season 8 it looked a little drier
[Music]
yeah it took on a totally new look with
an expanse of flat empty deserts
stretching out from the capital if
viewers had never seen the gates before
this might make some sense but
considering that audiences have spent
plenty of time looking at King's Landing
this continuity error is especially
jarring a coffee cup spotted during
season eights the last of the Starks
inspired plenty of jokes but thanks to
long hours and grueling shoot schedules
there's bound to be plenty of coffee
cups laying around Thrones as said and
most people don't know that this wasn't
even the first errant cup to be spotted
on the series during season 4 episode 2
the lion and the Rose which focused
almost entirely on an ill-fated royal
wedding a behind-the-scenes shot of the
Lannister clan catches Jaime Lannister
clutching a coffee cup of his own
fortunately this blender wasn't nearly
as bad as the internet made it out to be
since the scene was part of a
behind-the-scenes featurette that didn't
make it to the episode it didn't attract
as much attention as Daenerys his cup of
herbal tea in season 8 but it still goes
to show that there are plenty of
caffeine habits waiting to slip up the
stars on the set of Game of Thrones the
opening credits of Game of Thrones have
been lauded for their well-designed
imaginative take on the series giving
fans plenty of Easter eggs throughout
the years as well as spotlighting each
location prominently featured in each
season after years of moving across the
Seven Kingdoms with stylized moving
models of each major city or location
popping up to show where fans might find
their favorite characters this time the
season 8 title sequence changed
considerably focusing on the north and
King's Landing as the massive war
between the two factions of Westeros
draws to a bloody close another little
detail during the opening credits is the
fact that each actor bares a sigil next
to their name in the credits identifying
their House of the Seven Kingdoms from
Starks to Targaryen stew Lannisters but
every now and then in the early seasons
someone would end up identified with the
completely wrong house maybe the
showrunners hadn't quite figured out how
the credits would work yet but during
the first season sophie Turner plays
Sansa Stark was suddenly a Targaryen
Emilia Clarke who plays Daenerys
Targaryen herself ended up marked as a
Lannister
and Ian Glen who plays Daenerys is
faithful right-hand man Jorah Mormont
was also apparently
Grint Lannister this show does have a
lot of characters to keep track of but
these particularly obvious gaffes
probably could have been avoided it's
worth noting that these mistakes have
apparently been remedied since they
first showed up one of the most serious
afflictions and Thrones lore is known as
greyscale a super contagious virus like
disease that turns human skin into a
stone like substance and makes the
victim both unrecognizable and insane
spread by touch greyscale is notorious
and deeply feared even when the spread
of it can be stopped as it was for
Shireen Baratheon most of Westeros
agrees that greyscale is incurable and
must be quarantined even though the
audience learns later that you can
apparently just cut it all off and be
perfectly fine but nobody knew that
during the show's fifth season as Jorah
Mormont and Tyrion Lannister travel
through ancient Valyria to track down
Daenerys while floating into the city on
their boat they encounter a group of
violent men all afflicted with serious
greyscale although Tyrion escapes their
clutches Jorah ends up with a patch of
greyscale on his wrist and resigns
himself to a slow death during which
he'll never touch another person a short
while later however when Jorah and
Tyrion have met up with Daenerys in the
fighting pits of murine Jorah straight
up takes Daenerys his hand to save her
life since he still has greyscale at
this point he could have transmitted the
disease and killed her simply by
touching her after taking great care to
illustrate that Jorah can't touch anyone
at all so as not to infect them this
seems like a pretty massive oversight
even in the middle of a tense battle
scene Game of Thrones is no stranger to
huge battle set pieces and season six is
the Battle of the bastards a
long-awaited showdown between Jon Snow
and Ramsay Bolton was no exception
pitting the underdogs stark family
against the sadistic Bolton clan
considered one of the best episodes of
the entire series the Battle of the
bastards combined an incredibly
choreographed and gorgeously shot battle
sequence with real emotional heft and an
incredibly satisfying ending goodbye
Ramsay
it's no surprise that fans and critics
alike venerated the popular episode
which scooped up a whopping seven Emmy
Awards and categories that included
writing and directing fans were thrilled
to see John charge into righteous battle
with his sword Longclaw but in one
particular shot something seems to be a
little wrong with the blade as John
jumps onto his horse to enter the fray
his sword literally bends making it
obvious that Kit Harington was outfitted
with a rubber sword for this particular
shot John probably won't take down any
enemies with this but it at least gave
viewers a good laugh after the episode
air this is Valyrian steel during the
show's third season Jon Snow infiltrates
a group of wildlings only to fall in
love with Ygritte a fierce fire haired
warrior who spends most of her time
telling John Snow how much he knows you
know nothing Jon Snow eventually Ygritte
Falls hard for Jon in return and the two
of them set out to scale the wall and
make their way into Westeros with a few
other wildlings though Jon eventually
returns to the Nights Watch betraying
Ygritte she still can't bring herself to
kill him and eventually dies in his arms
when the wildlings staged an attack on
the Nights Watch leaving Jon feeling
pretty dang sad at the loss of his first
love Ygritte and Jon are still pretty
hot and heavy by the time they reached
the top of the wall along with a few
other wildlings and as they look out at
the green landscape of Westeros they
kiss passionately elated by their
achievement however their kiss is so
powerful it apparently knocks any other
wildlings right back off the wall they
just climbed since everybody else
vanishes by the end of the shot wanting
some privacy for such an epic romantic
moment is understandable that's just
taking it too far
on a huge show like Thrones there's
bound to be some prop accidents
especially when a lot of the props
involved are enormous metal swords meant
to look as menacing as possible as with
all fantasy series swords carry a lot of
weight with characters gifting naming
and gushing over specific weapons that
travel throughout the show a perfect
example is Ned Stark
sword ice which is melted down after his
execution and made into two new swords
named widow's wail and Oathkeeper
needless to say swords on the show are
treated with all kinds of respect but
sometimes extras might have a little
trouble managing these massive weapons
as Sir Barristan Selmy is unwillingly
discharged from the Kingsguard during
the first season there's a tense moment
in which it looks like sir Barristan
might try to start a fight
fortunately the moment is defused
without bloodshed and Barristan storms
off into retirement
at which point all the guards sheathed
their swords in one smooth motion like
the pros they are well almost all of
them put their swords back one of the
extras has some trouble getting his
sword back into his sheath which
embarrassingly for that extra ended up
making it into the final cut check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]